um are you dating anybody no don't even
thinking about it Khloe Kardashian is
single and so not ready to mingle you've
been on a date
no stop well not since Tristan and I
broke up yeah yeah
I have friends like I want to hook you
up with someone I just don't care I'm
focused on myself and true family is
what I do in a sneak peek at the
upcoming episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kris Jenner did what Kris
Jenner does best mom so hard and grilled
her daughter about her love life who
knows maybe I'll never date again Khloe
of course Khloe and Tristan Thompson
split in February 20 19 I'm it his
cheating scandal with Kylie Jenner's
former bestie
Jordan woods you know things happen and
of course I'm sorry and apologetic as
much as I can be in you know and Kris
well she just wants her little girl to
have it all Khloe has definitely been
through a rough year and the fact that
she says she doesn't want to date again
is a little sad for me because I want
her to live her best life and hope that
you'll have another baby one day and
while mama Kris makes this argument for
dating and I think it's good to put
yourself out there for a little bit in
order to figure out what you want and
what's meant to be Coco is shutting that
ish down heart do you want another baby
no-no-no are your eggs frozen nope if I
want to I will one day just don't care -
you need frozen eggs I'm not worried
about it and Chloe says she's doing just
fine on her own I just find it so
strange that people find it such a
negative when somebody wants to be
single trust me if I wanted to date I
would date I want to invest my energy
and my daughter and my self healing and
I think that should be really empowering
and it should be more rewarded rather
than frowned upon yes Queen I'm actually
and fantastic I think everyone needs to
jump on this bandwagon and all of this
echoes what Chloe told ET back in
October you guys have been through so
much in your life but what do you what
are you looking for now you're not
looking I'm not but I'm not like in ten
I'm just super happy and content and I'm
focused on work and like taking care of
me my body and soul and true and I just
I'm having so much fun with her and when
I want to I will it's not some
deliberate thing yeah she ain't that
hard about to be fair she didn't exactly
shut down the idea of dating as for her
relationship with Tristan that you have
managed to keep things cool and are
working on co-parenting their adorable
little girl true I think working on your
personal growth internally is something
that will be a forever mission and I
always want to evolve and grow and
mature emotionally because that's how we
become better people while the world is
changing around us we should adapt to
that too but always remember to be kind
and just courteous of what's happening
around you too
so I don't ever want that to change
[Music]